Okay, so here we have our design of the
classes we are going to build up on the top
right hand corner, and what I've done thus far is
created a new Python file, and I called it inheritance.py.
Now, based on our design, I'm going to go ahead
and create a class called Parent. There. The next
thing to do is to initialize the variables of class
Parent, variables like last_name and eye_color. So, to do that,
I will define this class as init method
or constructor. The first argument for this function,
we know, is self. And the two instance
variables for class Parent, we know, are self.last_name and
self.eye_color. Now the init function we know will
receive a couple of values as arguments. So, let
me add them in here, and we will
use these two arguments to initialize our instance variables.
Let me do that next. Alright. You may notice that this piece of code is pretty
similar to the code for class Movie that
we have written previously. By the way, one new
thing I will do here, is add a
quick print statement inside the init method. It will
print out, Parent Constructor Called. So, this print
statement will explicitly tell us, each time the init
method or the constructor of class Parent is called.
Alright, to make sure that this code that we
have written thus far actually works, let's go ahead
and use this class. I will define an instance
of class Parent and call it billy_cyrus, and will
provide the two arguments that are necessary. The first
of which is last_name and that happens to be
Cyrus, and the next one is eye_color which is,
let's say, blue. Now, a quick word
of caution. Ordinarily, I would have kept these
two things, the definition of the class
Parent and creating its instances. I would have
kept them in separate Python files. But I have kept them both here in the
same file for ease of demonstration. Okay, so to demonstrate
that the instance actually works,
I'll print out its last name. Let me save and then run this file. And
there's my output. It says the parent constructor
was called. Which seems appropriate, because we created
an instance called billy_cyrus. And as soon as
we did that, the class Parent's _init_ method
got called, which had a print statement inside
it. And then, we printed out Billy Cyrus's
last name, which it printed out correctly. Okay, so far so good.
Now, you'll notice that there really isn't anything new that we've done here
thus far. The new thing we're going to try is called inheritance, which
will happen when we create the class called Child. Let's do that next.